the suicide squad is just a twisted
fantasy of characters some of them are
just pretty crappy through and through
well just when we thought the suicide
squad reboot couldn't get any more
star-studded james gunn goes and
squeezes sylvester stallone into the mix
but
who exactly is he playing well we have
some ideas and we're gonna tell you
about it right now
on the ketchup you all probably already
know that director james gunn is
tackling a new suicide squad movie set
to release in 2021 called
the suicide squad you can't forget the
the which no doubt stands for
the cast in this film which is pretty
great because we have some returning
favorites like margot robbie and joel
kinnaman as well as some great new
additions like idris elba and john cena
the full cast list is really too much to
go over here but if you want to know
more about it be sure to check out our
previous episode on the entire cast if
you haven't already
let's say we still see but let's talk
about salon now casting details were
first revealed via teaser at dc's fandom
event giving us our first look at each
character in the film but one
new for the big screen character king
shark was notable as the teaser didn't
have any actor name attached
basically meaning that they had yet to
cast a role which makes sense because
the character is essentially cg
so could sly be voicing the character
well as much as a
giant beefy half man half shark kind of
makes sense for old sly the answer is
maybe behind the scenes photos show
actor steven gee
playing the character in a giant shark
head mocap suit no less and he's also
listed in the film's cast
to ask king shark but could that just be
a red herring
get it cause sharks eat red herring
forget it one thing's for sure
james gunn's recent announcement that
production had wrapped makes stallone's
late edition
even more curious because you wouldn't
think stallone would settle for a simple
live-action cameo role
until you remember that this actually
isn't the first time the two have worked
together in a smaller capacity
so stallone plays to car agord in 2017's
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 which gunn
wrote and directed and while that role
was mostly used to flush out yondu's
character arc
the character's inclusion was celebrated
by die hard fans because it was a deep
cut from the original guardians comics
from the 60s and 70s
and given james gunn's keen ability to
shine a spotlight on unconventional and
lesser known characters it's possible
that the same is happening here again in
the suicide squad
i mean the dc universe has plenty of
characters to play with and really
anybody who can turn a talking tree into
a household name should not be
questioned
it's also worth mentioning that back in
august fellow marvel alum taika watiti
joined the suicide squad in an
unnamed role and was also heavily
rumored to voice king shark
now that news was followed with the
announcement of a suicide squad spin-off
series with john cena's peacemaker for
hbo max details on that show are sparks
but it could give taika or sly more
screen time to show off whoever they are
playing if they are in fact only
cameoing
in the feature film more on that series
as we get it
seems like this establishment is the
wrong kind of disreputable okay friends
it's time for us to get over to you now
who do you think sylvester stallone is
playing in
the suicide squad and which new
character are you most stoked for let us
know all your thoughts and feelings in
the comments section and of course for
more movie and streaming news
head on over to rottentomatoes.com and
if you're still trying to wrap your
heads around characters like peacemaker
and kingshark you are not alone actually
so let's talk about this further in our
ketchup fan group on facebook
and if you don't want to miss out on any
future episodes of this show be sure to
hit that subscribe button and
notification bell and as always we can't
thank you enough for watching the
ketchup my name's ask prez and we cannot
wait to find out who sylvester salon is
playing
[Music]
bye
you